[Music]
well it's about 9 p.m local time and
super late our time so we're gonna get
to bed and tomorrow morning i'm gonna
give you a tour of this place
welcome to your first day on the big
island of hawaii
i got a little surprise for you
oh
aloha becca and i picked this just for
you
i love it thank you tommy thank you
sweetie this is absolutely amazing we
are here near the kona airport on the
big island of hawaii and we're going to
be here for two weeks and we've got this
rental house and it's absolutely
gorgeous there are fruit trees all over
this little property here let me show
you we got pineapples growing in our
front yard
we got some grapefruit trees growing
here
got banana trees
this is a giant banana flower and look
at all these little bananas growing up
here i don't even know what that is
we got papayas
becca would you like to sit here and
enjoy the tropical breezes while i make
breakfast oh you sweetie i would love to
alright guys we are gonna make a
hawaiian breakfast here it's gonna be
awesome
oh that is so perfectly ripe
i got ourselves the hawaiian sweet bread
here
oh that smells amazing
we've got some pog juice oh my goodness
papaya and yogurt and a little sweet
bread with lily koi jam on it
sweet sake bonito furikake
some rice foodie kake an egg fried spam
this is the hawaiian breakfast of
champions
would you like some spam and eggs oh
thank you honey i'll start with the spam
becca are you having a wonderful morning
having a wonderful morning oh good
oh
should we get up and do something or
just sit here until it's time to eat
more food
it's a tough call
this this is pretty nice isn't it
we've been out here on the balcony for
about what three hours four hours now
shall we get up and actually go out and
explore this beautiful island of hawaii
i love america damian notch
all right you guys ready to go explore
yeah yeah
all right
me and becca both been to the hawaiian
islands several times and each of the
main islands has its own unique flavor
if you're looking for a more affordable
hawaii vacation if you're looking to get
away from the crowds
then the big island of hawaii is
probably your choice
all right our first stop is dakota coast
state park we're gonna check this place
out look at all this lava rock guys
look and the feel of these islands
changes dramatically too depending on
which side of the island you go
most of these islands have a dry arid
side and then a rainforest side which is
just drippy green and rains all the time
the big island is a lot less crowded and
a lot more affordable but it doesn't
have a lot of perfect white sand beaches
like maui or oahu we tend to get a lot
of these rocky beaches or the coarse
sand but there's also a few black sand
beaches here there's just a lot fewer of
them
oh you're wet now aren't you
do you see a crab
find some coral i did pretty big
[Music]
well this is definitely a cool beach and
i think we kids are gonna want to come
back here but we're trying to explore
and discover a bunch of new places today
so we're gonna keep moving
you guys hungry yeah
let's go get some food huh all right
all right we got food
we've got
some chicken katsu musubi which is kind
of like hawaiian sushi huge apparently i
had no food it was that big
all right then we got some crispy duck
and we've got macaroni salad and rice
and then we have kaloa pork and cabbage
and macaroni salad and rice here grab it
take it take a big bite out of that
want that
it's just right
[Music]
no fried chicken
[Music]
macaroni salad and rice is such a
hawaiian thing hawaiians always have
macaroni salad it's good you can't blame
them i mean that's good stuff i think
the word is
um the duck leg
that tastes better i like it all right
guys should we go check out another
beach
[Music]
look at it this place is gorgeous
this is a national archaeological site
and part of the national park service
but also just a wonderfully beautiful
place what'd you find wait i found a
whole bunch of helmet urchins a whole
pile of them oh look at those i always
wanted the chocolate one
yo they're
it's alive though we don't want to kill
it should we put it back i'm going to
put it back
oh nice that's sea cucumber i was
looking for these can i see it
yeah it's like a giant
living turd
yeah there was a people like this
that's awesome
look guys it's a fruit stand let's do it
well i'm hoping you get the seeds out of
that and then you make chocolate sure
our bag is fine we're gonna eat it on
the road dad do you get a coconut i got
something different this is a mountain
apple who wants to eat a mountain apple
red ones you have a white one
and this is dried ginger
with a little bit of sugar on it
they taste like an apple but they're the
texture of a pear
after it tastes like a plumeria or
something
all right guys you want some shaved ice
yeah all right
you guys just wait right here
sorry guys they're out of ice
jungle turkeys
check it out i think it's a little on
your honor fruit stand
here babe oh
cool
let's let's see
so there's supposed to be a really
awesome black sand beach with some great
spear fishing down here
but uh this is quite the trail to get
there
weird cactuses
is nice
this is a pretty cool beach i think we
need to come back here on monday what do
you think
i think this has been a very good
investigative hike
oh look there's a cool shell on it
oh look at the size of that olympus
yeah that's a two incher right there
yeah but not today let's get it when we
come back on monday watch out watch out
there's some olympus right there
the crab right here i see it did you see
him
yeah it is
but isn't that cool
yeah
what do you think is this your favorite
beach so far
all right
all right guys we made it
like the locals are having a bit of a
party
nice
i'm hugging that coconut with my
hey
you guys want to come back and try some
spear fishing next week
well we made it back and removed about
five pounds of sand from jacob's diaper
but it's time to go to bed i'll see you
guys in the morning
it is another morning in paradise
becca woke up to a giant dog pile full
of boys
and uh i'm gonna make everybody some
breakfast and then we are going
snorkeling and spear fishing and it's
gonna be awesome
all right jake you want some jelly and
toast
all right hold that take that to the
table
what you guys want to eat some broken
glass yeah little bits of different
colored jell-o in pudding red
this is all like jello tastes like jello
yep
sure
thanks
holy nolly you caught a green nanoli
you call him anthony vianoli
anthony
all right our vacation has officially
started tommy has caught his first
lizard on this trip all right guys you
ready to go to the beach
almost nobody here see this is why jet
lag pays off you get up so early that
you can get to the beach before everyone
else all right let's do it
it's like maternity pants for spear
fishermen
using a wetsuit is kind of like wearing
chest waders with a leak in it just the
water slowly seeks into your bits
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
those are only the ones i could carry
back there were probably 30 of them in
that hole
oh that's incredible i love it if you
like that i love it
hey tom what do you got there mr krabs
hi i missed your crabs money money money
i work for the krusty krabs i am mr
krabs oh i'm tired but the kids are
having fun nathan's setting himself in
the sand
and tommy and jake are feeding crabs of
dead fish
rebecca are you having fun
hold on let me see
oh
there's an old one
smells like a pull out of my pants
all right
whoa
those are beautiful way to go i love
that
tom what are you up to oh i'm feeding
this crab i can see his claw
feeling better to get out of the wetsuit
yeah
we go go get some lunch and go see a
really cool value oh nathan don't get
all sandy well guys that was loads of
fun but we're gonna go grab some lunch
but check this out look at this beach
this is all the people that you see
on noon on a saturday
this is not crowded
and that's the big difference between
the big island and some of the other
islands in hawaii mom and the boys are
back at the house getting changed and
cleaned up
so i'm going to go over here to nephi
smokehouse get some good food
[Music]
oh this smells good
just saw a sign saying lays for sale i
think i need to get back another leg
there we go
there we go nice little honor system
business there
got two fresh lace for my lovely wife
and cost about a third of what the ones
at the store did
oh my goodness you sweetie
aloha my love oh thank you do they smell
good they smell great
oh they smell great i got you one for
sunday too
that's your church one let me show you
what we've got
okay this is smoked sweet sausage with
macaroni salad and rice
this is laulau which is like
i think smoked meat wrapped in banana
leaves it's kind of a traditional
hawaiian thing
this is korean short ribs or caulby and
we've got smoked pork for dessert
we have six deep fried poi balls
fermented taro root uh poi which is a
traditional hawaiian food
and of course mommy gets strawberry
guava juice i love the hawaiians they
think this is like servings for two
people so they gave me like two utensils
thank you
oh i like that
it's like mochi it's uh really chewy and
squishy
um
but just a little bit sweet
i worked up an appetite swimming around
all morning
oh those play balls are good should we
go on a little road trip or should we
sit on the couch and just enjoy the
breeze all day tough decision
tough decision road trippiness come on
baby
all right let's go to waipio valley
look kids goats
[Music]
every day and every night
they have coconuts for sale all right
guys we got a fruit stand let's do it
cut coconuts yeah i saw we picked a
[Music]
coconut coconut after you guys are done
drinking it
here guys why don't you take it and
share with mama
well you wanted to try it you can try it
do you like it
like a hawaiian lady in the [ __ ] thing
huh
um those sugar cane aren't like for sale
because i use them to juice you want to
go play on the swing yeah go for it you
just gotta film it
check this out oh that is gorgeous
that's bread fruit
mountain apple mango lychee i think
that's a rabbutone
dragon fruit
little baby bananas
oh my goodness this is the papaya
mango you're about to have the best
papaya of your life that's
andy can you get the skin
that is really good papaya nathan you're
saying you're hungry
all right these papayas were amazing and
so i've got a couple of those for
breakfast tomorrow does that sound good
yeah yeah it does
look at that
this is waiapio valley if you have a 4x4
you can drive down to the black sand
beach
and when covid's not a thing you can
also hike about six seven miles to a
campsite and camp there which mean
anything we're going to do but campsites
closed
[Music]
try that
good
[Music]
sometimes it's
okay
all right we got fresh passion fruit on
toast with passion fruit jelly and the
extra passion fruit to just spoon out
and eat as is looks like frog eggs but
it is delicious
they're beautiful and it's your third
day in hawaii so here's your third one
they're beautiful and they feel very
good jill thank you
that was amazing
oh that's so good well guys it is a
beautiful sunday and me and the family
are gonna go to church and uh they're
gonna go around and do some exploring
and go drive around the aisle a little
bit you guys excited yeah
now guys you need to be really good in
church here in hawaii there is a long
tradition of beating children who are
naughty in church
what
we're back from church and we're going
to do a little road trip so we're making
some uh peanut butter jelly sandwiches
for the kids but mommy and daddy are
getting passion fruit peanut butter
jelly sandwiches
oh that's so good
you guys ready to go on a drive
hawaii is fascinating you'll drive a few
miles and the ecosystem and the climate
will change dramatically we're just a
few miles from kona and it's 62 degrees
it's kind of chilly up here
oh you got telescopic rods
there's rainbow falls near hilo hawaii
pretty cool
[Music]
all right guys who wants mommy tofu
[Music]
whoo-hoo mama dime
guys would you like some dessert yeah
i think we should make some special uh
ice cream floats what do you think
this is melon flavored ramune yeah it's
a japanese soda drink and this one's
cantaloupe flavored
i think my ice cream is like melting it
well guys it's another beautiful day and
i'm up early to run a few errands before
we get started
we've got pancakes with bananas and
macadamia
nuts and coconut syrup and we've got
waffles with the same and we have the
clove pork almond with portuguese
sausage ooh this coconut syrup smells
amazing
boom that is good
clue pork omelette oh
oh
oh
that's really good isn't
breakfast has been the highlight of this
trip
well we have a beautiful day ahead of us
so we are going to go to that remote
black sand beach we hiked to a couple
days ago and we are going to do some
spear fishing and snorkeling there and
maybe get some limpets you guys excited
yeah
yeah
do it let's go for a hike
don't want to be nice
when they're
all big strapping teenagers and we can
make them carry everything they'll
probably complain about us slowing them
down which we'll find very offensive and
ironic holy sand is blazing hot i've got
flip-flops on and it's burning me
look
at this
isn't this cool
oh my god
get in the water put your feet in the
water put your feet in the water
despite several warnings jake ran onto
his head and just started screaming and
running for the ocean now he's kind of
trapped
we'll deal with that one
well i want to do some spear fishing and
i am super jazzed to do it how you go
hop in
[Music]
so
[Music]
uh
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
whoa that's gorgeous
no
it is all yours
have you ever seen anything like that no
it's gorgeous that's incredible again
luke saw spear fishing there's a pot of
dolphins
oh i can't believe i i got to swim with
dolphins that was so cool
yes jacob dolphins are real
coming into short all said something big
and silver
what was that
i'm tired i bet hey boys you want to go
get some limpets
all right
you find one
oh yeah yeah yeah
wait
oh that is a good one nathan that is a
big boy
nathan look at that that is the biggest
one of the day
see
look how easy that was
there we go
see just got them out of that shell
usually we just eat them whole but these
ones are so big we can actually take the
guts out of them
and just cut off it guys
there you go
i actually dropped them i had one that's
actually better than some olympics i've
had live in lunch you like them
what a beautiful place and a beautiful
beach look at this
oh man
other than the dolphins we've had very
little company this has been really
really cool
man i only found one good shell today
but boy did we find a good shell look at
that thing
can i hold it yeah be very gentle it's
so fragile
only way we would have oh
it's good you've lost shell privileges
it really is a fragile shell all the
times i've gone to hawaii i've never
seen one like this this was a pretty
cool beach wasn't this
oh we made it
this is
this is ivan's that's gravy fries
oh and this is
katsu curry and this is loco moco which
means crazy booger in spanish so
oh apparently it is fried egg on
hamburger patties with gravy and rice
and macaroni salad
guys it's been a great day we will see
you in the morning
[Music]
it just smells and feels amazing out
here but uh becca's parents are coming
today so we're just going to kind of
take it easy and get the house cleaned i
got to do some editing and
it's just going to be one of those
low-key days hi jake you having fun yeah
and evening
you're a t-rex yeah
hey tom how's your day going good good
you want to go get some lunch with me
yep how about some raw fish
we're going to get pokey pokey boogie
boogie boogie
sand joke
all right so poke is hawaiian sashimi on
rice we're gonna get a whole bunch of
this it's gonna be good
see
show you
that soy sauce
octopus salad yeah
there's baby octopus you want that
another floor we got some for your
parents oh thank you
hey guys let's come over here try some
poke
soyu ahi which is basically soy sauce
and yellowfin tuna tofu some seaweed
furikake and white rice wanna try a
little seaweed yeah
you want to try some yellow fin buddy
the rice is the best part
what do you think jacob you like that
we're getting farther away
all right grandma and grandpa at the
airport you guys gonna go pick him up
all right tommy you go take the camera
oh i'll be doing the viewing
aloha
hey guys welcome to hawaii well thank
you
well becca just picked up her parents
from the airport
we're gonna get them situated in the
guest room here
all sorts of different tacos here we've
got kahlua pork we've got barbecue beef
we've got jackfruit we've got chicken
and i'm not sure which one is which but
they all look
pretty amazing
another day comes to an end and i'm
sitting here out on the veranda with my
my lovely wife eating amazing food you
having a good day babe
we are going lizard hunting
nathan do you want your neck
oh
she saw a lizard
oh they're fast they're fat
oh oh there's one on the ground there's
one on the ground
oh look hey look at that little toad i
caught him
oh there's a gecko right there
i got him i got him
see look at him hey can you oh there's
so many cockroaches in here did you see
the size of that cockroach no
oh look at that i got it i got another
one no hold still
hold it oh
my god daddy
oh
i need to find a pet cockroach
oh here's that that will catch you oh
there he is oh got him ha ha ha ha i got
one look at him look inside
oh he likes me hi cocky look at the size
of that guy he's not even he's not even
the biggest
all right guys i think it's time to go
to bed we caught a ton of lizards and
toes and cockroaches
well good morning it's 7 a.m and i'm
loading up the car to go meet a fishing
guide to go on a spear fishing charter i
really want to learn more about spear
fishing so one of the best ways to learn
is to go with the professional you got
everything you need yeah i think i do
that's definitely all right my
instructions were to meet a guy under a
mango tree behind a construction place
love you baby love you bye bye bye babe
all right i'm here with jeremy with
topshop spearfishing and he's doing a
really awesome intro class here going to
walk me through all the basics of spear
fishing something i desperately need and
then we're going to get out and go and
try it so i'm pretty excited to cover
some really great breathing techniques
okay if you probably imagine why it's
called a pipe gun kind of yeah the
density of the waters so it's good yep
but uh all right we got our gear on
we're gonna go into the ocean do a
little bit more instruction before we
start poking some fish
take your time
turn the camera on if i'm gonna bite it
i'm gonna get it on film
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
holy mackerel guys that was so much fun
but that kicked my butt my legs are
jelly
like oh that was such a sweet video well
listen guys if you want to come to the
big island or to maui and you want to go
and dive with these guys and learn how
to spear fish or if you wanted to go on
a little more advanced spear fishing
trip check out top shot spear fishing
i'll put a link down in the video
description below aloha guys
i am so hungry we're all going to go
back to nephi's smokehouse here and get
a bunch of food including those poi
balls
lots of poi balls
here we go we've got a gravy
cheeseburger
korean cobby beef
korean fried chicken
constant chicken smoked pork
laulau pulled pork and banana leaves
and more boy balls
i am so hungry i could eat this all
myself
oh my goodness i am so full of food and
it feels so good oh
man that spear fishing just takes it out
of me
but it's a low-key day that we don't
really have anything planned for the
rest of the day and and so i think i'm
just gonna
edit some videos and we might actually
leave the house we might not
[Music]
oh
[Music]
there we go hawaiian bread french toast
with passion fruit juice and jelly and
coconut whipped cream
it looks great
you like that
that's a big bite for a little boy oh
there we go got a nice little breakfast
made and two out of three of my children
think it's disgusting so you know there
we go that's parenting in a nutshell
but we're up to an early start because
uh we want to go hit a hit a nice beach
this morning and uh we want to get that
out of the way because we've got a
pretty extreme adventure
this afternoon
isn't this cool we're walking through
the forest
well we got our own little private beach
and cove here with tons of crabs and
tidal pools so the boys are happy
i'm gonna get all geared up and i'm
going to try to go out and poke a fish
all right let's go snorkeling
so
food
there we go guys we got dinner
check it out
thank you have you had a good time
three four five six sea turtles i can
see right there
i've seen a sea turtle every time i've
been to a beach here in hawaii
you guys have a good time yeah yes yeah
we had a great time excellent all right
guys who wants some fish
[Music]
hey jacob will you help me eat that yeah
you're big do you want to bite the tail
you like the tail
yeah
so apparently this little fish right
here at coley it's kind of like the
bluegill of hawaii and it's a really
popular fish to serve at weddings and
other gatherings like that you can just
peel the meat right off the bones
that was good
i like that all right guys you know what
we're gonna go do we're going snorkeling
with manta rays
and we're doing it in the dark
[Music]
all right guys we're here at kona
snorkeling trips it is just about sunset
we're gonna hop on a boat and we are
gonna head out into the pacific ocean
looking for manta rays and we're gonna
be diving in the dark becca are you
excited i'm excited
so mantas don't have any teeth they
don't have a stinger and they don't have
any barbs
[Music]
all right guys we're here just a little
bit offshore from the kona airport and
we are here to see big manta rays and
when i say big i mean six feet wide and
bigger
and we've got a surfboard right over
there with high powered lights they're
going to attract plankton and the
plankton's going to attract the manta
rays sun's going to set here and we're
going to be in real darkness here
getting into the ocean it's going to be
pretty awesome
mom's right there
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
holy mackerel that was amazing those
things are huge it's so hard to get a
feel for the size of those things on the
camera but
i mean
[Music]
it's it's cool being in the water with
the creature several times bigger than
myself
were you freaking out was that a little
freaky
did you see the manta ray jacob
no
no you guys have a good time
listen if you guys want to come to the
big island and swim with manta rays i'm
going to put a link to kona snorkeling
trips down in the video description so
definitely check that out but we gotta
get to bed
well good morning me and becca are going
on a dive charter this morning and uh
grandma and grandpa and our three boys
are all feeling a bit sunburned and just
a little tired so uh they actually
wanted to stay home so just me and becca
are going on a scuba date i've never
been on a scuba date
i think we wore everybody out back up
no kids
what is this see how quickly we got out
of that car becca were we ever like this
no
it would have been up there
baby shampoo
just make everyone feel dirty at home
because there's less things to do with
your right hand okay
[Music]
[Music]
ugh
[Music]
so
ah
yeah are you having a good time i had a
great time we thought spotted eagle ray
oh nice oh you look like a pro down
there
that's one way to anchor the boat
our filter feeders so they'll be turned
whichever way the current is
[Music]
[Laughter]
do it one shot i'm getting better
man we have had just a wonderful trip
and we've got about 30 minutes left so
we just stopped here in this little fish
preserve and uh me and becker just gonna
snorkel and check out some fish together
[Music]
okay
[Music]
guys we had an absolute ball if you want
to come here to the big island do this
check out big island divers
and i'll put a link down in the video
description
thank you guys so much
well that was amazing but we've got some
fish to clean
that's why they call them surgeonfish
because they have these little scalpels
on their tail
rebecca was that fun it was really fun
this was a great one it was a great one
hi
becca's feeling a little motion sick so
i went to the grocery store we're gonna
see if we can't get something that's
gonna make her wanna eat here
strawberry cheesecake popsicles a little
salty cracker baby
oh do you like cream puffs
i've got shoyu chicken and rice if you
want to eat something right now
and i've got a bunch of teriyaki bees
all right good morning we are off to go
catch some massive marlin
there you go
man this is one of the best places in
the world to catch big marlin
look at that popper
got some dolphins over here and over
there
giving us a good morning greeting
[Music]
the nice thing about hawaii you don't
have to jog for an hour and a half to
get out to the gulf stream or something
like that
that's the harbor and we're already
putting out rigs
[Music]
[Music]
well we didn't catch anything but did
you still have fun oh i had an amazing
time especially when i spot that sea
turtle yeah
that was pretty cool that's how it is
fishing for blue marlin guys they're a
big game fish so if you get one or two
hookups a day you're a lucky man mom's
gonna pick us up we're gonna go back to
the condo and get some dinner well good
morning guys it's a beautiful sunday
morning and we're just here making some
breakfast
all right guys let's hop in the car
well we had a good time at church tommy
caught a lizard
it was a baby it was cute all right
we're just gonna be making some lunch
here i'm gonna be cooking up all these
fish and got some vegetables and rice to
go with it it's gonna be nice
[Music]
all right we got all the fish meat
deboned we got some fried rice avocado
asparagus a little soy
all right guys should we go for a little
sunday drive yay
we're at place of refuge national
historic park and apparently this is
where
the king
used to be
so lots of artifacts and interesting
historic stuff so you can learn about
the indigenous people why
that's a rain jacket and you see up
there those baskets those are fish traps
so apparently this is where they kept
the bones of the old kings
the kids mutinied at the thought of more
driving in the car and so we dropped him
off the house with shelley and we are
going to drive up mount mauna kea
up as high as we can it's actually one
of the tallest mountains in the world
because it starts well below the sea
base it's actually taller than mount
everest
well guys we're up as far as we can on
the road without a 4x4 so uh we got to
turn around but we're at
9170 feet above sea level so
uh we got up there pretty quick engine
was definitely struggling a little bit
but if you want to hike about six seven
miles or if you got a four by four you
could drive all the way to the top which
is at about 14 000 feet i believe so you
can drive to the top of the largest
mountain in the world i believe shall we
head back down
i guess so
well guys it's the end of another
beautiful day and we're just listening
to a tropical rainstorm from the comfort
of the veranda
we're gonna call it a night and i'll see
you guys in the morning well good
morning guys we're cooking up some
breakfast and i'm getting ourselves
packed because me and nathan are going
on a great backcountry camping adventure
all right we need to get nathan in his
clothes
there we go
you guys ready to go to volcano yeah
yeah
keep our boys safe
full of water
now we have about a nine mile hike
across this lava flow to the ocean where
we're gonna go try and camp on a remote
isolated little cove and you see the
only way you can tell the trail is
there's piles of rocks
leading off approximately the direction
that my gps is telling me
oh there's a little pile of rocks right
there
all right we're on the trail just follow
the piles of rocks
see look at this you can see where the
lava just came down here and kind of
piled up and slowly cooled
one of the hardest things about this
hike is that there's no fresh water
anywhere on the trail so you got to
bring all the water you need for the
entire camp
out you know we got a lot of hiking to
do today and a lot of hiking to do
tomorrow so we're going to stop every 30
45 minutes and just take a little three
minute break
and uh we should get there no problem
all right
we can finally start to see the shore
and it's long ways away
look at this
what's this
what is this out here
smells good
it's a guava my goodness this is a white
one
it's a little tart
these are all guava trees
yeah this one's a little more ripe
here
i love guava
well that was an awesome little surprise
i can see our campsite from here but
it's far away
look at these pretty flowers
you like some snacks
all right i got some snacks here all
right i got some hawaiian snacks here
including this bag of macadamia nuts
they're super high in calories this one
bag is 1600 calories
i have some linghimui covered strawberry
gummy drops the sugar will help give you
a little more energy
oh these are so good
okay buddy
nathan you okay bud
nathan you always fall when you least
expect it yeah so we should expect it
we've been hiking for three hours now
and we haven't seen another single
person the whole time
that's a tank of water that services
backpackers but
heard that they've been having drought
have any water
rangers have been telling me they have
so much drought lately the water is
unreliable
i'm gonna sleep like the dead tonight
tommy would love this place it's covered
in coconuts
look at this
might see it
yeah i totally might see a turtle
oh look at this this is beautiful
this is gorgeous
look how beautiful that water is i could
just sit here and lay on this beach for
hours
but we need to find a camping spot it is
going to get pitch black here in about
45 minutes
you can barely see it but that palm tree
stump right there and there and there
are all carved with these faces on them
it looks cool
there's like a good spot let's camp
right here
oh you hungry buddy
chicken burrito bowl mre here we're
gonna heat them up with a little bit of
water
okay we're gonna sandwich the tortilla
and the chicken burrito bowl with the
heater take about four or five minutes
okay you ready for a tortilla
of my corn nuggets on here
just hold hold the bottom so it doesn't
come out the bottom yeah there you go
burrito cheers
for you
hi i've got to get to bed i am
absolutely
shot my legs are jelly
and uh
i'm running a little low on water i
brought a gallon of water and i've used
up like 60 of it that's something to
worry about in the morning
right now
we are just in an absolutely gorgeous
spot listening to the waves
just gonna have a good night's rest
it's about seven o'clock the sun's
setting
we're gonna pull up my phone watch a
movie or two
and i'll see you guys in the morning
[Music]
hey good morning
your legs feeling
good completely better oh good
so becca dropped us off here
and we went all the way down here
but instead of going back i think we
should go
and take this trail all the way
to there
that's
2680 feet that's an elevation of 132
feet
[Music]
all right for breakfast we have coconut
butter mochi
a hawaiian delicacy that's full of
calories and sugar there you go buddy
it's a great trail snack
[Music]
what a beautiful spot
you're not very tired
oh good well i'm glad you had a good
rest then
it's good that we got an early start so
we can beat a lot of the heat this way
we're just hiking through these thickets
but every once in a while there's a pile
of rocks you can get on top of them and
just have the most gorgeous view
all right setting my alarm for 15
minutes we're gonna rest every 15.
don't eat the whole thing maybe but just
uh take two or three well every time we
take a break we'll stop and eat a couple
fruit snacks
all right nine and a half miles to go
we're on the edge of two different lava
flows from the volcano kilauea
over here that's from the 1960s
and this lava flow over here is from the
1970s
[Music]
lay down
take a little break nathan you did good
that was a strong 15 minutes
my water is low
it's the alarm i know that one
still
taking my mouth full of
ah we water
it across the lava field
emoji break
[Music]
it's kind of shiny
[Music]
all right
here we go
little mre pizza
this little oasis is the apua campsite
beach
it's where i was originally planning on
hiking to
but i found out you can't fish there so
i thought i'll go a little further
and go to japan
i really regret that decision
if i had to do it over again
i would have brought an extra gallon of
water
and we would have camped here
and then came straight back
and only had a 12 mile hike instead of a
20 mile hike
it's the last of my clean water
with lava crystals
but it's like
little long bits of gold and glass
oh it's kind of like touching fiberglass
don't touch it ouch
[Music]
i can see the road
the end is near
we only about 1.7 miles to go
well i lost about 40 pounds since april
so if i'd done this hike in april this
is what it would have felt like
oh
no wonder i was so tired all the time
there was a lot of promises made about
ice cream i've written checks that we
need to cash
[Music]
nathan you just hiked 20 miles how do
you feel yes
so so exhausted yeah guys i am beyond
exhausted we are gonna go get the
biggest thing of ice cream ever and as
many cold drinks as we can fit in our
stomach
cars are nice i like cars hey nathan are
you gonna walk to the lava tubes with
mama
geez you're a hardcore i may never walk
again i hope you have a wheelchair at
the house we're gonna check out a lava
tube
nathan you're incredible i am amazed
that you are up for this
here jake wait for us buddy
this looks pretty cool guys
ethan you're amazing you just walked 20
miles and now you're going through a
tube like it's no big deal
stop don't
run just walk
wait for us
it was amazing
do you know that this little nathan boy
at one point was running we couldn't
keep up with him
sounds like him
just give him a rest and he's good
hi jacob but that lava tube isn't as
amazing as your hair oh
look at that
do you guys want some ice cream yeah
all right you guys ready for some ice
cream
hey can we get an extra cup for one of
these uh hand that hand it to mama oh
thank you very much
that's your iceberg
that's my iceberg
oh it's delicious that is half a snowman
so yours is the hollow hollow which is
shave iced cream ice cream caramel
uh sweet potato ice cream and azuki
beans um yeah there's coconut in it
coconut it's like if a shave ice and an
ice cream cone had a baby and they
divided fruit cocktail over for for part
of the fun
yeah you know
ha ha good morning guys well i'm a
little bit sore after yesterday but uh
we're taking it kind of easy and finally
we've gotten up gotten dressed and now
we're gonna go to the beach one last
time before our trip is over
all right
thomas
hey ryze pleasure to meet you how are
you doing well all right guys we're here
with ryan myers here he is a spear
fisherman that
goes all over here on the big island
today he also has his own youtube
channel which is really sweet if you
guys want to check that out put a link
down in the video description below he's
going to try to see if he can help me
get a little a little bit better at
spear fishing
anything
all right we're here at this lovely
local beach i've got the whole family
here becca is gonna be sitting in
painting
and uh the kids are playing a little
title pool with some friends oh what'd
you find
today oh yeah look at that one that
one's that one's like a number two
pencil that thinks
jump like this you know so you don't hit
get out there wet belly flop
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we got the fish look at that go back
beachside fish fry
yes
holy mackerel
you yeah i can see it you can see right
there
he's got those it's got glow in the dark
lines on him
all right guys we got a big mess of fish
we're going to make a campfire we're
going to cook them up that's the best
part of spear fishing is fresh fish for
dinner that would be terrible yeah right
now
did you help get all the scales off that
yeah got a got a frying pan with some
peanut oil going here getting that all
nice and hot
and over here we got some fish getting
nice and seasoned he scored the skins
and sprinkled some coarse garlic powder
on there
oh
the sun's going down
we got mampachis we got coles we got
king coles
all in one pot
yeah i wanna grab that that fish by the
tail and start gobbling it down i'm that
hungry that looks so good oh they do so
good don't they
it's really right now jacob are you sad
because you want to eat fish right now
well come eat some fish
yeah
pretty amazing right
oh that's so good yeah
it's amazing
we're trying to break it
tell me did you see the rainbow oh dear
look at that sunset isn't that beautiful
ryan man thanks so much that was so much
fun seriously guys if you want to see
some hardcore free diving and
spearfishing check out ryan's channel
what's the deepest you've ever dove i've
been to 260. 260
feet on one breath that's aquaman crap
that's it right there so anyway check
out his youtube channel i'll put a link
down in the video description becca was
that fun that was so fun well guys we're
back here at the house and it's late and
we've got to get the kids to bed and fed
and get the house cleaned up because
tomorrow is our last day in hawaii we've
got a lot going on but we're going to
have some fun we're going to do some
cool things tomorrow and i'll see you
guys then
well good morning guys it's our last day
here in hawaii our flight isn't until
like 9 30 tonight so we gotta check out
and then we're gonna go and cruise
around the island and eat some good food
we're gonna get some hawaiian donuts
and uh just have a good time
all right everyone say goodbye to the
rental house
[Music]
all right guys we're getting some kahlua
pork and some laulau pork it's gonna be
good apparently this is the local spot
all right
it was a pleasure talking with you
it was telling me about how babies were
born
so super jay's only has three items on
the menu there's laulau pork la la
chicken and kahlua pig with cabbage and
then all those come with macaroni salad
rice and like salmon pico de gallo or
something like that all right i'm gonna
try some kahlua pig
smokey good cabbage
that's not bad at all well guys did you
enjoy the food
do you want some donuts yes
okay we're here at the puna lou bakery
and we're gonna get malasadas
all right thank you very much
all right guys these are malasadas i
believe they're a portuguese jelly donut
it's gotten really popular here in
hawaii
oh look at this oh what kind are they so
this is lilly koi or passion fruit
that's a traditional i believe that's
guava filled this is guava flavored and
then that's strawberry it's so good
whatever it is
who wants passion fruit i do i do all
right guys you like those are those
tasty
okay we're driving down the road and
there is the biggest playground i've
ever seen in my life this is higashihara
uh park
here just a little south of kona so uh
we're gonna check it out
oh geez
this thing's huge
dave have you had a good trip had a
great trip i am really sad to leave let
me do
[Music]
oh guys we had a wonderful trip and i
hope you guys enjoyed this video as much
as we enjoyed filming it if you guys
want to check out any of our other
travel videos check out our travel and
adventure playlist i'll put a link in
the video description below thanks for
watching and we put out new videos every
saturday morning so don't forget
click subscribe if you like this video
don't forget to check out the outdoor
boys youtube channel where we have
hundreds of videos just like this and
don't forget to click subscribe so you
can see other great videos every
saturday morning hit that bell button
you'll get notifications thanks for
watching
[Music]